I've been looking forward to talking to
you all week okay so we have to talk
about this fight between you and your
sign what can you tease about the
aftermath what went down when you got in
the car and what we're doing you got
some hotel the only thing I confuse
about the aftermath is that if you know
me you know I don't play okay what did
you do I know you can't say everything
but can you give me a little bit more I
just you know I gave him regular old
regular jugulars regular Brittany so
that's good were you afraid to leave
with him at all cuz I was afraid for you
I saw that look in his eyes and I was
like it's really really going to get in
the car and go with him were you afraid
at all um no just because I mean his
that behavior in that moment it was like
shocking but after dealing with my ex
and you know I did like grow up for the
most part in Palm Beach but I am from
79th Street and Chicago so not much
scared yes act that way before so that
was like a real shocker so you have you
ever got that mad before no you know
he's usually very calm and very sweet
very understanding so that was just like
I was think he must need a nap or
something funny but looking back now do
you you understand a little bit why he
was so upset about it I thought like you
having the liquor and buzz no no because
I didn't know anything about that being
a problem beforehand if he would have
shared that with me and been you know
kind of open with that I would have
probably not done it but yeah like
acting like accepting like he didn't
care what Benny flipped off so so do you
think he still has similarities to your
ex like do you like looking back now do
you still say yeah they have
similarities I think common have
similarities with my ex I think
some things you have to check out the
door before they just get as extreme as
my ex Scott so you know some things I
just have to check out the door with him
it's not I don't think it's anything
when I'm dealing with someone when I
especially from a different background
and he's the things being a certain way
and we're learning to compromise I think
sometimes when you just have to check
things out the door that you're not
willing to accept and yeah in happy
actually listen so what you check that
the door like has has behavior change at
all I think that like we both me and
audience will have to see that
throughout this show because I think
it's different when you're looking at it
when I'm like looking at it on screen
like the situations that are going on so
honestly I kind of want to just take
myself out of the experience of going
through it and just like kind of wash it
and see that he actually make these
changes okay that's a good way to look
at it well we know that years on and his
parents are expecting your divorce
papers so what can you tease about
what's gonna happen when they find out
that you don't have them um I mean I
really can't say much about that yeah I
really can't say anything about that not
even just because like I can't use it
but because I'm still like processing
everything that happened as well so I
kind of like I'm not ready to speak on
it yet so again okay so that good news
or bad news okay that it's not bad or
it's not good it's just regular it's
like regular life like especially when
to like obviously like I said before
we're so so different so if we're coming
from two different backgrounds we're
gonna be going through a lot of
conversations and a lot of compromise so
basically it's normal for the situation
where do you feel think all the
compromise is worth it it depends we
have to we still have like time to see
if the compromise is worth it I think
it's too soon to tell so far I think you
know everything has happened the way
it's supposed to and I'll enjoy
enjoying the ride can you tell us
anything about the status of your
divorce um I really can't speak on the
status of my divorce right now so yeah
okay all right are you considering
converting to Islam or it use on if
that's something that you may now be
thinking about now I'm not gonna convert
to any religion for anybody so yeah yeah
I don't think that's a good idea for
anybody okay for God if you're gonna do
it it should be forgotten not for me
very true I definitely agree with you on
that
how was it were you wearing a hijab for
the first time um it was fine I mean
like it was just like okay I still like
you so how do you like you yeah you did
like you actually um yeah that express
that his culture has very modest
standards and he had concerns over the
way you dress I see you know you have
won your nice little sweater it's really
cute actually
right now but do you consider like
changing the way you dress for use on to
make him happy
that's something that you are willing to
sacrifice if I sacrifice anything or do
anything it's gonna be for myself
because I decide that it's a good
decision it's not gonna be for anybody
else or any man because that's the only
way I'm gonna stick to it if it's really
myself and it's really something I
believe in
so you know I think it's unfair really
to you try to change yourself for
another person because once you get
tired or fed up I that person or
something so I don't want to be in that
situation with you I was on smart move
how's your dad I love your dad everybody
loved my dad honestly wait and you could
tell he wants you to go out and live
your life but as a father he just he's
like you're his baby yeah my dad
actually learned a lot raising me and
dealing with me and stuff like that so a
lot of the women are leaving a lot of
comments like oh my
your dad is so great and I'm amazing
that's because of me because yada raised
me near you he had to put up with life
so yes he knows how to deal with women
and be understanding in people you know
he had to raise his daughter and you
know I teach him a lot about women and
he is such a good guy he's a smooth
cheek guy he's a great catch for some
reason you know what you said for some
reason what it's like not dating he's
like a workaholic he likes to work and
I'm sure there are so many women that
would be up for dating your dad yeah I
get more comments about my dad and he
has on on my page stuff Wow something
needs to change there everybody's asking
for my dad to have a dating show like
right I would actually watch that you do
you think like you would be happy living
in Jordan for years to come I love
Jordan Jordan's amazing what do you like
about me I just I don't know I like the
people I like the culture I like the
different things that it has to offer I
love the natural beauty of it the
deserts and all that stuff it's just
amazing and I just hope like people are
get to see like the different side of
the sides of Jordan throughout the
season I feel like I want it to really
what really interested in me doing this
show is like you know getting that side
of Jordan out cuz when I went I was like
wow like this is so different than what
you would expect hearing on the news or
something like that they try to make it
seem so bad and dirty and stuff right
nice so what's something that surprised
you the most where you were like wow oh
I really like this about this place or I
didn't expect this I don't know I would
say the beautiful restaurants the
beautiful or delay like just the scenery
all the animals I love animals so there
was this like
so many animals like all over the place
and I thought you mentioned the dog or I
heard you mentioned the dogs how they
are different over there yeah those
songs are crazy like you don't don't you
dare go on those dogs block they would
you uh how did you overcome the
communication barrier in Jordan did you
use like one of the apps are some things
we used apps and I pushed em to go take
English classes so I will go with him
every week good classes and I was
sitting in the class with him because
not because I wanted to but because he
always would make me go to his class
look am I used to be like no so yeah
really you're one of the main reasons
why he was doing it something yeah and
then you would go home and like I would
help him like with English homework and
stuff and I would give him little
assignments to do it or hope and because
it's good not just because like I want
to change him but it's there for him so
he can get more opportunities you know
what I mean cuz if your English speaker
in Jordan you have more work
opportunities so that's what I was
really like trying to push him to do it
I love that you're here you're elevating
what is it upgrading yes okay yes okay
so did you make any friends enjoy and
that's one of my questions like other
thing is on and his family were you able
to get out and meet so maybe new
girlfriend's or something I'm girl I
can't even make friends here I can't
even make friends in my regular life or
you the girls here don't like you but
you know the girls don't like me so they
think like they never seen anyone like
me before anyway like first of all and a
lot of them don't speak my language so
and then when they see me with Yas on
they're just like what is he doing with
her like right girl so you know it's
just really hard and then you
and America it's hard for me to make
friends too because people just like us
soon like I'm mean or something and I'm
not like I'm really a nice person I'm
just like introvert most for the most
part I like keep to myself so right I
understand that girl sometimes new new
friends aren't necessary you know if you
have everything you need what's the
point
yeah yeah are you going to continue your
rap career in Jordan that is like I've
been waiting to ask you that I feel like
like it's not really like a rap career
like I love doing it it's something that
I love doing but you know I got a lot of
business going on so it's not you know
it's not a it's not a priority but
something beautiful that I enjoy and I
put it out there so yeah I'm gonna
continue doing it I'm probably gonna
continue doing until I die do you want
to give this a few bodies would you be
up for that I don't want to give a few
bars right now cuz right now I have like
something in my mind that I'm like kind
of working on so I don't want to get
myself jumbled up I want to keep those
bars in my head okay
a little fly it until I get it down on
paper get it on a beat so sorry but I
don't want to mess myself up no no
worries none of this I was like too
cheaper you know fur for people who do
like rapper music but I just figured I
might as well you know do you think that
unions ons relationship can withstand
like looking at it right now do you
think it can withstand your cultural
differences um yeah I feel like the
world
we live with stands all the people in
this world we will stand each other's
differences if not everybody girl cuz
we're dealing with a lot now but
everybody but for for you know for the
most part you know a lot of people
usually tend to just try to mind their
own business you know when you try to
like overstep your boundaries and you
try to change someone else that's when
problems arise
you got to change people's opinions and
views that's when problems arise you can
you know talk to people and have them
sympathize and empathize with you but at
the end of it all you can't force that
person to change so I think that's
you know I just try to focus on and I
believe that's what yes on is trying to
focus on because he kind of gets you
know where I'm coming from and the type
of life that he wants to live and we
want to live in the future so yeah on a
scale of one to 10 how's your
relationship with his parents right now
can you tell me I want to say that I do
love Yasin's parents I I don't know
exactly where his parents stand I can't
speak for them and I won't speak for
them but I will speak to say that I love
them and I do think that they try their
best to deal with the situations at hand
with their experiences and their
lifestyle so I think they're just doing
the best that they can I don't blame
them and that's their son 100% so that's
their baby and I understand all of that
well what can you tease for us when it
comes to the rest of the season what
what will we be seeing I don't even know
since I haven't seen what they have in
store for them what do you remember as
far as when the cameras were there
filming any big moments what can't see
me being crazy family drama yes I'm
being crazy family drama me being crazy
family drama family drama me be crazy me
being crazy me being crazy family drama
got our bar today but we got our bars
right
[Music]